I mean I'm not at all jealous of your
beauty no seriously you trying to
squeeze your pregnant dresses I so I get
in you I'm not pregnant but the same
thing happened to me it's not Spanx for
pregnancy regular daily oh my god if I
were pregnant would not wear Spanx you
just own it
now yeah it's kind of comforting you're
saying oh you know it kind of holds it's
escaping yeah separate thing I'm glad
you're pregnant not me very pregnant
sorry yeah it's just second right second
I'm so excited it's been amazing
first pregnancy was really easy Evie was
like a dream pregnancy this time around
also really great but everything's
happening faster it's I'm swelling
faster I've heartburn faster I was way
more not just this time around so it's
just like yeah absolutely
opposite sex is happening I know
so is this did you ever have like any of
the weird stuff like either cravings or
weird dreams or yeah anything like that
oh so many weird things I only had
dreams of not being pregnant you were
like please yeah no I with Evie I was
super healthy I wasn't actually fine I
wanted grapefruit which was like ah
Thank You Evie currently can't see any
it's fine yeah exactly like no no this
time I'm like I want junk food
I want everything bad is really but it
was immediate where's the chips like
where's Joe Bell like I was like I
needed like I can roll with this kid all
right I'm the dream did you have the
crazy pregnant I literally only dreamed
of not being pregnant not an actual joke
yeah no I dream really weird this
pregnancy I had a dream of the night
that I was playing hockey with a bunch
of hockey players and then all of a
sudden we turned into balloons and we
started floating and the problem was we
couldn't keep our skates on the ice I
woke up I was like I need to feel
grounded I have no idea I mean
fragmented Wow you in the dream just ice
skating break yes playing hockey other
thing that I do
in the dreams yeah really weird oh my
god I missed out on the fun dream you
know I would have woke up trying to like
get some dream book figure that yeah
what's wrong with me I know I just
looked over I was like that was so weird
I'm like why am I dreaming of hockey
ever ever I'm super excited for you very
cool thing I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this